I don't know
whether it's the egg or the chicken I
don't know which comes first I do know
that
Hollywood has a liberal reputation
and I always cringe
when I watch the Oscars
and wait for some beautiful talented
actors to say something stupid about
some
some issue yeah but to tell us that
we're all racist now come to my movie
yeah right
and it's kind of silly and and it should
be seen as silly it should not be seen
as
I hate her I'll never talk to her and
I'll never go to her movies
and uh
they take it far too seriously in that
way
is that what strikes you as as most uh
the starkest difference between the say
sort of self-proclaimed Communists or
socialists of today where it really is
sort of let's burn it down as opposed to
let's operate within the system
something like that I think I I think
that if
are aware of the history of
American labor or
middle-class development or anything
you're going to know that America was
strong enough to accommodate a legal
communist system Communist Party
from the very beginning it never once
was attacked as illegitimate
the attack was
like extra it was they didn't even
include the legitimate party the
Communist party they just attacked
the that weird entity known as communism
and it was an international something
ghost-like craziness
and and
Stalin gave them good reason
to fear them
and the guys that I knew who were
communists
were always Communists because of
domestic
reasons because of the depression
because of lack of work
and things like that
they were not
um
uh educated to International
you know Marxism Etc
and that stuff can be pretty easily
dispensed with you know you don't have
to read Marcus to to understand
that it's illegit you know and it's too
bad that it wasn't allowed to just
Duke
you know have a Duke out
an intellectual debate between communism
and and
it's like the the Nixon uh Khrushchev
kitchen debate that they had uh that was
important that was an important thing
and it actually really made a difference
you know they because Nixon
um
stood up for Commodities and private
Enterprise and like that and Khrushchev
uh wanted to you know nail him to a wall
too bad
you could have learned something
[Music]
and to turn over a country's a country
as big as Russia
and turn it over completely to a bunch
of approachniks
that didn't know anything about the
Industries they were running
not a good thing and ultimately we're
gonna fail
sort of sort of sounds a little bit like
what we have now with a lot of people
that are running things that don't know
exactly what they're doing so you
mentioned that you would describe
yourself in sort of different ways you
obviously became
A-list Hollywood star for several
decades but Hollywood is known as this
you know sort of Lefty socialist
whatever place they're not too kind to
some of the ideas that you're writing
certainly about in this book about
Civics and pride in America and things
like that
um I know you think it's uh well I don't
put words in your mouth but I think you
believe it's affected your career later
but do you think it affected your career
early on I mean there was obviously a
tremendous amount of success there
uh you mean did was I frightened by its
negative effect on me yeah never Yeah by
not beaten by not just jumping in and
yes I'm just like you guys on everything
no I never it never occurred to me to be
like that it never occurred to me that I
would be hurt by it and when I have
friends who are on the other side who
are you know conservative writers and
such who say that they've been
blacklisted I like to turn to
uh my friend Lionel chedwin and say
Lionel you have not been out of work
since Hanoi Hilton
always working don't tell me you've been
blacklisted and and I think that there's
a kind of romance to being blacklisted
so you want in on that but we uh we play
fast and loose
with our insults and pejoratives and we
don't explain enough
I think that there's more books
that come out recently that are written
by conservatives who call liberals
um
Traders
basically Traders
and that's crazy
and any and and liberals who do the same
thing about conservatives are nuts
and they should control themselves
and one of the things about Civics is
that you learn
how to be civil and that's a controlled
way of communication
and if you can do that
you can always come out on top
all discussions
do yelling and screaming and
interrupting
you lose and we lose
do you sense that part of that is
because the culture has gone so Askew I
try not to blame all the politicians all
the time for how screwy everything seems
because they're just a function of us
and culturally we at an educational
level we don't teach a lot of these
things we don't teach Civics that well
our education obviously public education
ain't great to say the least the stuff
that now comes out of Hollywood and
through big Tech and everything else
it's often very slanted that that sort
of we're having like a cultural crisis
in a way that then leads to the
political dilemma that you're talking
about
I think it's
I don't know
whether it's the egg or the chicken I
don't know which comes first I do know
that
Hollywood has a liberal reputation
and I always cringe when I watch the
Oscars and wait for some beautiful
talented actress to say something stupid
about some
some issue
yeah but to tell us that we're all
racist now come to my movie
yeah right
and it's kind of silly and and it should
be seen as silly it should not be seen
as I hate her I'll never talk to her and
I'll never go to her movies
and uh
they take it far too seriously in that
way
and
and conservatives
make it far too
serious when they were in the 50s when
all the owners of the companies were way
over to the right
and they and they would hire liberals to
write their Scripts
and and they they created a picture of
America in small town Andy Hardy ways
that was beautiful and very persuasive
and they had no women no blacks no Jews
nothing it was a Protestant small town
in America
and
it was as
wrong-headed as
you can get
and
but that's okay if as long as you let
the other side have it say
you know let the conservatives have
their say and the conservatives do not
have to be Ein Rand
they can be small town America
and
one of my favorite films
is the Oxbow incident
and that's the story of a town that goes
mad and hangs the wrong guys
and at the end of that film when the
sheriff comes and says he's not dead
he's he's at his Ranch and anyone who
participated in this
is going to be up for murder
and that's the whole town
[Music]
there's it's a complex thing it's
nothing is so simple and for us to make
uh
the the claim that politics can be
simple
it's not fair it's not right
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell